he fast that he pressed that button with
some SASS
and a lot of women that go on her
podcast they all have the same
experience so I do think that she's
quite anti-women and I think especially
um like ethnic women now I'd like to say
after the podcast the girl in the middle
sad I don't want to be involved in any
controversy now I just want to see her
face in the middle does she look like
she does not want to be involved
colors
you will see an ethnic woman there you
will see it it's apparent in mind I was
doing the recruitment yeah so it's
really hard when somebody can't say the
word ethnic and when they come onto the
show and they say oh when you go in
there and she's anti-women we are not
anti-women how can we react to women
when we are women our mothers are women
our grandparents are women our
grandmothers are women aunties are women
so we're not anti-women maybe it comes
across like that I personally am
anti-dum
[ __ ] women that is what I'm anti right
so if you want to say that I'm
anti-women make it clear I am anti dumb
women I am anti
[Music]
yes I am Auntie dumb
women and also I'm an ethnic woman yeah
I want to give a little um pretext to
the to the audience so this is the
domino effect podcast
um Eddie and Daly on the right
um Eddie did recruiting for us for a bit
and they have their own podcast for
friends with them the guys on the left I
think I met once they've been on our
show and the girls in the middle both
came on my show as well
she said women shouldn't vote correct me
if I'm wrong
because they don't they shouldn't have
the right to vote because they don't
know what they want for dinner
well you can look at them
[Music]
and I was I said look at it look at most
girls don't know what they want for
dinner so how the hell are we gonna
choose the leader of the Free World
exactly but I think what she's trying to
say is that she knows what she wants for
dinner so she confirms no no but
actually no what I said was that women
we don't get drafted the same and so
like in the US we have um something
called Selective Service yeah and women
aren't enrolled in that and that
basically means if there's like a time
of War like men have to go in the draft
Yeah and historically that's why women
didn't vote was because we couldn't be
drafted and I said if we're going to
vote let's make it equal yeah and if
you're going to make it equal I wouldn't
want to vote I I that's what I said I
would give it up if I don't want to go
to war I don't want to fight yeah so I
want them in that if you don't want
equality you go for it but I don't want
it I don't want it because I don't want
to go to wall I know I will be cooking I
swear to God up in the kitchen I'll be
on the floor scrubbing the floor I'll do
anything rather than go pick up a gun
and go out there and shoot no no so if
that means equality and you have the
right to vote well I don't want equality
because I don't want to vote because I
don't want to get drafted women
shouldn't vote because women make
emotional decisions which means that
when politicians are trying to sweep
perspectives it's easy to manipulate
women into one way or another of course
means that when you're making bigger
decisions for the country the people in
power are straight by people who don't
make decisions based on logic okay and
you you just have you just prove that
you just proved that now don't let me
just show you hold on let me just shut
you let me go they have they're
interrupting everybody and they
interrupted Us in the show and then they
go on somebody else's show and they
don't know anything about podcasts
etiquette oh and that's the thing the
guy on the left was trying to talk and
they talk over everyone and they both
did that on my own show and then they'll
say that they weren't given enough time
to explain yourself I'm like how much
time do you need oh shut up no and and
that's what you'll do watch every time
the guys try to stand up for us or make
a point or say something they interrupt
or they try to interrupt every single
time and I'm like how not self-aware are
you
the same way let me shut you down
emotions let me shut you down she even
admits it let me shut you down yeah and
it's their show that's the that's the
crazy thing cool thing it's based on
your hormones right naturally there's
some women with higher testosterone
levels naturally so naturally some women
don't make emotional decisions some yes
so now hold up hold up now because of
that do you see the guy on the left it
wasn't five minutes and he's so done the
thing is is that whenever you go on a
podcast you're always talking about the
majority they might be minorities out
there they might be an exception to the
rule we ain't got time to go into
deception of the rule we are always
going to talk about the majority it's
always going to be about the majority is
your IQ level it's you that information
and seeing what's right for the country
right there are men with lower IQ than a
lot of women yeah I hear that so if some
if women are making emotional decisions
in your basement because some might
react in a certain way and they can't
they'll they might be swayed there's
also men with low IQ okay and let me
just jump how many members of low IQ are
running countries out there it's active
yeah so one of the reasons why behind
the idea of the fort is the perfect
thing to look is that is finances here
so women own two-thirds of Consumer Debt
why is that because women are easier to
sway in One Direction or another so
you're gonna have people who we all know
that men have more money than women
generally yeah women make the majority
of consumer decisions even though they
have less money and you're going to
leave them to make decisions for the
country no and that's not and I'm okay
you've already made one bad emotionally
she's doing it again Daddy's trying to
talk the host the host of the podcast
and she doesn't let him talk and guys
this is what she did the whole show I
swear to God the whole show I did it you
have nothing I'll tell you why you're
saying because it's just the thing yeah
a man now a man now yeah like obviously
someone have beef and whatever and won't
jump on a podcast because of someone I
think these are the guys from Birmingham
yeah they are yeah oh yeah but for me
yeah you're saying you wouldn't have
jumped on because of pill that's answer
I gotta say the man on the right watches
Expressions while they're talking he's a
comedian watch his Expressions when the
women start talking rubbish should I
tell you what no Should I tell you why
why because you don't like it I like
podcasts a podcast is about
conversations right and it's about it's
not having big she didn't have a
conversation she got on the show and she
spilled her guts
I remember you saying why are you keep
on talking she spilled with her guts
it's like damn near a therapy session it
was like she told this whole story and
why do I know this about about her baby
father about and it's like what will
happen is I'll ask a general question
and if there's something too private
that you don't want to share don't share
it but if you if you tell the story and
then we ask more questions you can't be
offended because you told the story like
I've been on podcasts where like people
have asked me a question and I just say
next question I don't want to answer
that oh I say that's not my story to
tell yeah yeah but you don't get on
there and just spill your guts and then
complain because people know all your
business and then so I'm backtrack
that's exactly what they're doing I'm
gonna call her away it's abuse it's
about being able to sit there and
explain each other and everyone taking
on that concept and understanding it's
an exchange of words right right you
used those subjects a big interview to
you it's bigger should I tell you why
her following is a
no how come you didn't tell me I was
joining the cult wow it's a call that's
crazy what is the definition of a call
okay a cold is a system of religious
veneration and Devolution directed
towards a particular figure object oh
definition two a person or thing that is
popular or fashionable among a
particular group or sexual Society I'll
be worshiping you then you're the cult
leader I guess I don't
okay
she's coming in we we been let you
finish
how unaware are you this is the least
self-aware okay I want you to like count
I swear to God and she's gonna watch
this she's gonna get mad don't care
um I want you to look at the podcast you
were on with me and look at this podcast
and count every time you start talking
time it time it and count what percent
of the podcast on a group of six Utah
talk when you are not the host and you
know what the girl next door I want you
to do it too because you talk damn near
the whole podcast of my show too and
then I'm the bad guy okay because and
I'll tell you why because I'm a very
reasonable person and if you what does
she sound like a reasonable person she's
not listening to anyone she's not
allowing anybody else to talk I'm still
waiting for her to land I landed I
landed from Gatwick on Friday on
Saturday quicker than she's lending now